さあ皆さんお待たせいたしました2021
年夏の甲子園カッコあら決勝のカードは
静岡県代表枝川工業高校
愛するは高知県代表
富士カー商業高校の対戦です二今日は私し
またとが移設はこのアホのような大会を計
555年連続優勝されている名投手へ
ダガーはじめ選手とお送りさせていただき
ます宜しくお願いしますよろしくお願いし
ます
さあエラー選手この試合まずはどう予想さ
れますでしょうかいやーやはり中傷という
ことで業務を選手結構疲れがきたはご覧
ください監督もも疲れているという詠唱が
続いておりますが決勝なのでぜひ8チーム
頑張ってもらいたいと思いますねはいこれ
から非常に楽しみになってきます
ただいま試合は9回の裏藤川商業99点の
リードで最後のエラー工業の広域を迎え
ます
これはかなり苦しいですね
ちょっと逆転できるか
青いユニフォームの藤川商業最後まで0点
で抑えられるか
頑張ってを付け猫や外野のフェンス
ぎりぎりの部分で工業のチームが
ウォーミングアップをしています
これはとても迷惑行為ですねドイツ何やっ
てんですかね
秀美
攻撃ですよで次なんでこんなところが
アップしてるんだ保育普通であれば素振り
などをする時間帯なんですが本当に迷惑な
行為です差し上げるやーんめっちゃ脚
あげてますね
ん
そしてこちらがやってまいりました宇治
カーショー今日の藤川球児監督です
日本のプロ野球
そしてメジャーリーグでも大活躍した
スターですすごいね
ないでしょっ
さあ監督の第一声なにしようかという言葉
でしたにしようかやーさすがにはパワーで
ティスついてたらあればもう何とか号を
買ってるみたいな感じなんですかねぇ
そして桜ガ丘やったことがないらしい興南
高もありましたそれで決勝までこれたなぁ
はいやってくれるでしょうから
彼らにやりましょう
そして五十川工業高校の選手はほぼ全員
骨折ということで今回の決勝戦は韓国も
含む3人での挑戦になります回転率早せず
に
はそして最終回ピッチャーは青い
ユニフォーム正選手です二課商業は逆転
できるよああ
断熱から声が飛んでいますバッターは金沢
劉璋です
こちらどんな選手でしょうかこの選手は
最近麻雀に目覚めたらしくてですね
夏て感といいますかはいその何かを揃える
打ったり当てるという
滑るので
はしっかりとりあえず塁に出たいところ
ですねそうですね120キロという表示が
ありました速球にバット今日は当てられる
でしょうかピッチャー第二級です
ここから v ノーボール2ストライクと
なります q も118キロのストレート
これは速い球だけますねー
さあこの後も3球三振となってしまうん
でしょうかッ棚沢ピッチャーセット
ポジションから第3球を投げました
ちょっと専科球外してきましたボール1
ストライクに変わりますよく見ましたね
パンパンとボールに慣れてきたそんな感じ
もしますね
さあここ売って欲しいところですねさあ
ピッちゃった4球を投げました当てていき
ましたさあここで初めてオールがバットに
当たりました
こう今すごいベンチファールでも大喜び
先輩でしたね本当に野球をやったことが
ないというのがこちらにも伝わってまいり
ますさあ一席のような一度ですよで大満足
なんでしょうか様々会にボールを飛ばせる
か第5級です
ブーブー今すぐさーああああこれ外角の球
を当てていったんですが穂てもての頃
すげーなーとこの選手一回も言ってやった
ことないんですよねぇーただこの全力疾走
です間に合わないと分かっていながらも
全力で走るこれぞ夏の甲子園カッコあら
ですハーイ高州園球児の良い子の
スポーツマンシップを感じましたがやり
切ったそんな表情をしていますすぐ悔し
そうな顔してますねエーサー
ああああああ
さあ球界のレバーマークで迎えるバッター
は植村です枝川工業
こちらの選手はどんなすきでしょうか
いわゆる脳筋夫今そこサイン出してるん
ですけど特に意味はないんですけど伝わり
ました
の表情伝わってるんでしょうか伝わって
ますね大丈夫です
さ第一級のいいダークの魂は少ないって
そうちゃん119mm 等
羽根町あのなく b 長いの経験があって
ねかなり築地から強い方ですねハワイと
言えばなしかし魂魄にお降りのは表じゃ
ないエアー
やっぱ0
ここ大事なところですねええ
なぜ熱気でてノーボール2ストライクから
第3球を投げました
さあバットに当てていきました夫
なぜだなぜそちらなしで子大豆はですかね
これ
ジャガー
こういう逆ですかね
いやー藤川監督もにガーラです三塁に走れ
ばったかねこれ野球やった方がないどころ
かルールも知ってる知らないとこれはもう
カンナによく決勝まで来れたんだよねそう
ですね
さぁ気を取り直してノーボール2
ストライクからの第49です
投げました fああこれは安定は当たった
カーっていないやこれ審判苦笑いで
ファーストの方振り逃げで走れという指示
を出していますが
キャッチャーもう kei 行きました魚
です三振という判定になりましたご覧
いただきますが美味しかったんですかね
これは一層ですねこのまま走っちゃうわ
じゃあボールを落としていますので空振り
はしましたが走っていればファースト
間に合えば
塁に出られたというシーンでしたなんで
このシスコとふてくされたような顔すんだ
よねこれはは審判を見て
数詞本当に不思議な表情していましたから
なぜここに私はいるんだろうみたいな表情
されて
サイズは丁寧にちゃっちゃー可能活性は
アウト
2アウトになりました
俺行ってくるわよろしくお願います
ございますさあそして満を持してエラー
干拓しましたねはいきましたね
バッターセンター
バット忘れた焦れたようですねー
男にとらん
どこに取りに行くんでしょうか
はピッチャーキャッチャー審判ともに
待たされます
まあ不穏な空気が流れてもええこれは棚沢
選手さんには植村選手も後使っていたん
ですがそのバッドではなく円柱らに下がっ
ていきました
直監督も不思議な表情しています
あった男ね英語よ
沸騰されたんですかね
を貼っをコーンのバッドは私の見間違い
でしょうかないか大きいように見えるん
ですがそうですね若干大きいように見え
ますね
振りもちょっとこの振りづらいように
見えるそうです
骨はまあ
野球のルール的にはややラガー
ちょっとっ
俺と勝負してくれませんかウットここで
サボン爆死ならー
対戦してみたいからちょっとすごいですね
これなら北
ウズかあさんに勝てると思うんです
僕の広さはそれ降っています
お願いは行ってみたくなった行きましょう
打戻はいじゃあすごい展開ハイポンチョっ
てくださいですおっウインカー館た表です
ねあふれる闘志
見られる歌詞の魂ストレート
ホールすごい試合ですね藤川球児た家
もう
資格外のバッハ4
すごい試合でセ
まずこれちょっと持つのが本当に大変そう
ですが
海と当てていくことができるでしょうか
そうですよなぁあってればワンチャンあり
ますからねぇ
さ投球練習
藤川球児が黒いってちょっと暗いというの
はあのリジェンとじゃないですかああです
ねーなー方とこの野球お手合わせでき
るっていう幸せをぜひこの枝選手には
かみしめていただきたいですねそうですね
改めてプロ野球ファンのメジャーリーグん
そして日本代表としても2006年にせ9
年の wbc を制しているそのメンバー
でした
無礼に当たるようなことですねそうですね
ほんとに怒られるようなことだけはしない
でほしいです
先生みてくださいと今はい
かなりをされていたあーこれ優しくお願い
しました日を使ってくれるぞ
佐田1級ですおっと管理末振り遅れました
んですねいそくかなり早いですねもうこの
急速900キロ越えのたまにはこの大きな
バッタでも当てることはできないか訴えだ
ぜぃ大丈夫ですねこれこれもうちょっと
バッドよりも先に枝精子がダメになって
しまうのではないでしょうか第二級です
投げました
当たらない
こんなに内閣でしたが a 先ほどよりも
ボールにあってきているような感じはする
んですがうーんもうそろそろ限界っぽい
からねぇなんでこんなものを作ってしまっ
たのかそういった表情にも見えますと安易
に当たるかなと思いまして絶対サンキュー
です当たらない分
渡った
わずかなというふうに勝っすぎました
いやーこのバッグを作った甲斐がありまし
たねああお金もったいねえ
パックがダメだと
ここで仕留められるかというか球児愛する
はエラはじめ番号の登録は降るのを諦めた
や basara
アヴェダ頑張って走る呪文美脚で関ジャ
ピッチャーとって pass out ば
柄に届きませんでした惜しかったなぁ
3アウトゲームセットですさあリプレイ
ご覧いただきます
最後は
芯で捉えた打球でしたそうで無理やりいっ
ただ前に飛びましたらぽてぽての
ピッチャーゴロ
ら選手もこれ最後はもうちょっと緩めて
ますよねそうですねもうたぶん彼も年なん
でね
さあ最後のばまあがピッチャーゴロに倒れ
ました
いやー悔しいだろうなぁ決勝で負けるのは
ええええ
ということで藤川商業史上初の99点差で
の決勝戦を勝利優勝となりました夏の甲子
園確保等
全チームメートが寄り添ってくれてますね
全チームメイトですが2人しかいません
はいさースコアボードを改めてご覧
いただきます10点10点10点と並んで
9回の表これでもかと言う止めの19点が
入り99対0富士カー商業がエドガー工業
下しました
さあ試合は最後挨拶ということになります
行チーム全力出せたんでよかったんじゃ
ないですかね悔しい思いはあるかもしれ
ませんが
エドガー工業の選手もやりきった表情をし
ています
雷終了
改めて99体で時間商業の勝利です何度
審判に上げてませんこれ俺もアップルは
笑ってしまうほど
白熱した試合だったんじゃないですよねは
それだったらいいですけど
ん99体で夏の甲子園学校等今年はこれ
にて終了ということになりましたはい
ありがとうございましたありがとうござい
ましたまた来年
はい数機で藤川さんとちょっと僕施策をつ
か言いながら戦ってみましたありがとう今
さーんいう
ブーブー
夜鷹
にょろ
さというわけで私肇社長姉な号執念で
アンバサダーにすぐにいたしました
ございますこれからですね番組とコラボし
たり色々なクリエイターと一緒に阿部真央
盛り上げていきたいとおもいます天まで
ですね f リーグ国内サーフィンつは
なしゴルフ下部ツアーなどいろんな
スポーツの特恵を含むな待受配信をして
いるそうですしかも入寮集計多数その中で
もですメジャーリーグベースボールが
とても暑いということで今日は府塚さんに
お話をお伺いしたいと思います宜しくお
願いします藤川さん mlb ではどんな
センスで注目です
[音楽]
here os が0-12や選手たちス
12や選手とのフォームを争いを繰り広げ
ていますのでぜひそこに注目してもらい
たいと思います本命なんだと分かりやすい
ですもんね
もう愛のみんな成長 were here
てぃない年とかもっと若い20代前半の
選手たちが素晴らしい成績を残しているの
で超残してないんですちょっと毛根なかっ
たことに情けなくなってきました大丈夫
ですか彼らはこれくらいのパットを持っ
てるゆきオイルですねすごいですという
わけでまだまだ見逃せないですね阿部まで
は毎日放送そして多くは無料中継しており
ますので是非皆さん見てみてくださいそう
いうわけでほんと氏ねシャルナ子ロボで
すごい感動しております今日本当
ありがとうございました僕も一緒のだから
親こちらこそ得られるよろしい思います
[音楽]
here それくらい楽しい
2時間ですありがとうございましたハゲ
運用は99対0ですねそうですね出直して
きますねあっほんと何か良いバッグを使っ
て改良してとか雰囲気は大丈夫かなぁ
あるいはさーんされました
dl
[音楽]